صحراء خضراء بيئه افضل بهذه الرؤيه دشنت
دوله قطر المعرض الدوليه الاول من نوعه في
قطر والمنطقه معرض اكسبو الدوحه
2023 على امتداد اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون
متر مربع من المساحات الخضراء وتحديدا
حديقه البدع في قلب الدوحه اكثر من 80
دوله ومنظمه دوليه ومحليه تشارك في المعرض
على مدى 100 و79 يوما خلال الافتتاح حرس
رئيس مجلس الوزراء القطري وزير الخارجيه
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني على
تاكيد ان النسخه الحاليه من المعرض جاءت
لتكون دعوه للقيام بمبادرات وشراكات جاده
من اجل عالم بيئي متوازن وان فعاليات معرض
اكسبو الدوحه
2023 هي جزء من المبادرات التي تتبناها
قطر في اطار رؤيتها الوطنيه
2030 اليوم تتش الدوحه مجددا باحتضان حدث
عالمي ينسجم مع التزامات قطر في التنميه
المستدامه وطنيا
ودوليا ويشكل اضافه نوعيه للمبادرات
المتنوعه التي تتبناها قطر لضمان مستقبل
اكثر امانا واستقرارا لشعوب الارض كافه
وخلال الاشهر السته المقبله سيستقطب
المعرض نحو 3 ملايين زائر ليكونوا شركاء
في ايجاد مزيد من الحلول الصديقه ل
في مختلف نواحي الحياه من خلال ورشات عمل
لاتاحه الوسائل لتحقيق اهداف اكسبو الدوحه
بالتزامن مع وتيره التغييرات البيئيه
المتسارعه ياتي اكسبو الدوحه
2023 ليكون خلال الاشهر القادمه من خلال
التعاون الدولي بدايه لايجاد حلول لتحديات
البيئيه وابرز قضاياها الامن الغذائي
والتغير المناخي وتحقيق الاهداف العالميه
لتنميه مستدامه ساره رشيد الجزيره الدوحه